okay so the topic of our video today is
one of the four categories of organic
molecules
you know lipids are one of the four
categories as are carbohydrates proteins
and nucleic acids I have a separate
video for carbohydrates proteins and
nucleic acids if you're interested but
today we're gonna focus on the category
of organic molecule called lipids so
let's get started okay so as we go into
our discussion on lipids no lipids are
what make up fats oils and waxes now
lipids kind of have a negative
stereotype a negative connotation of
them because we hear the word lipid and
we see it's associated with fat and we
think it's unhealthy and horrible and
zero fat is good well here's a couple
reasons on why biologically we need fats
fats provide energy for cells so we can
break down fats and get get ATP energy
from them through the process of
cellular respiration lipids make up part
of our cell structure you might know
that phospholipids make up our
phospholipid bilayer the outer boundary
of every single cell in our body you
look at this picture right here of an
elephant seal well this elephant seals
very fat it has a thick layer of blubber
which is a great insulator for it it
swims in very cold ocean waters and so
has to be able to keep itself warm so
lipids are very much a needed part of
our diet we just don't want to of course
overdo it and put ourselves at heart at
risk of health effects so when we look
at the cell membrane here we have the
blue double phospholipid bilayer right
here in this picture and our cell
membrane the boundary of every single
cell in our body is composed of a layer
a dual layer of lipids called
phospholipids so there's another reason
why-y-y lipids are just really biola
biologically important they composed the
bound outer boundary of our cells and
embedded within our cell membrane is
another type of lip
called cholesterol again cholesterol
kinda has a negative image negative
stereotype to it because we see the drug
commercials with you know medications
designed to lower our cholesterol but we
need a healthy amount of cholesterol it
gives the cell membrane its flexibility
it prevents the phospholipids from
bunching up too much or spreading apart
too far so we really need a normal
healthy level of various lipids so when
we look at the structure of a lipid I
want to start with a collection a small
grouping of atoms on the top of the
molecule this that's why I call it the
head and this small collection of atoms
is what we call a glycerol molecule and
I've just simply shown it as this blue
circle and attached to the head attached
to the glycerol head it will be a couple
maybe three or so chains of what are
called fatty acids dangling down from
them and so in this picture I have two
chains of orange fatty acids dangling
down but you may have heard of what it's
called a triglyceride the reason it's
called a triglyceride tri means three
triglycerides have three chains three
tails of fatty acids dangling down from
them so lipids don't always have to
sometimes they have more than two chains
of fatty acids well this is a very
simplistic picture right here here's a
more realistic picture of what a lipid
might look like this is actually a
phospholipid so not only does it have a
head made from a molecule called
glycerol but there's also another
molecule called a called a phosphate
group well we'll talk more about that if
you watch my cell membrane video but
there's a clump of molecule a clump of
atoms at the top called the head and
then you can see there are two tails of
fatty acids dangling down in this
picture and we mentioned in another
video that organic molecules are made
from monomers and polymers and so the
polymers have believed just what the
overall object is the lipid and the
lipid is made from smaller parts called
fatty acids and you can even add
glycerol to that fatty acid endless
would be the monomers well let's move on
so how do you get that glycerol molecule
right there that's the actual structural
formula of the molecule called glycerol
how do you get that glycerol molecule to
actually bond with those three chains of
fatty acids right there well I hope you
remember that there is a chem a chemical
chemical reaction where small molecules
will bind and make larger molecules and
that's called a dehydration synthesis
reaction with the help of enzymes
they're gonna break some bonds and
remove water and so watch this I just
highlighted the the water that's gonna
be removed look at the fatty acid on the
left with the removal of water now look
at the fatty acid in the middle with the
removal of water this is a dehydration
synthesis reaction and now the fatty
acid on the right again
enzymes help to break these bonds but
when the enzymes break the bonds and
water is removed notice we now have one
really large amount like y'all made from
the glycerol on top and three fatty acid
tails that are dangling down attached to
the glycerol this is again a dehydration
synthesis reaction it's how molecules
are built up so kind of the opposite of
dehydration synthesis well how would
this large lipid right here how would
this be broken down into smaller parts
the kind of the opposite of a
dehydration synthesis reaction is what
we call hydrolysis with various enzymes
and look at this with the addition of
water one of the fatty acid chains has
been broken apart here we have a second
water molecule breaking apart the second
fatty acid and here we have a third
water molecule breaking apart the third
fatty acid so hydrolysis breaks
molecules down dehydration synthesis
builds molecules up so I want to mention
he's probably heard of some fats called
saturated and other fats called
unsaturated I want to mention the
difference here's a picture of a
saturated fatty acid I just mentioned
that lipids are made from a glycerol
head and a fatty acid tail well
of those tails are what we call
saturated fatty acids and others are
unsaturated fatty acids so let's first
of all look at saturated fatty acids
notice how there's a long chain of
carbon-carbon single bonds anytime you
see a carbon bonded to another carbon
there's a single bond in between now if
you look on the far left of the picture
yes there is a double bond on the far
left but that double bond is between an
oxygen and a carbon so if you only look
at the carbon-carbon bonds you'll always
see a single bond here and so what we
what we mean by these fatty acids are
saturated what saturated means is that
it's just full with you know a sponge
can be saturated with water just means
that the sponge is full of water so a
saturated fatty acid is simply full or
saturated with is full of hydrogen atoms
and notice how the fatty acid is in a
straight line because the fatty acids in
a straight line you know one fatty acid
will typically stack on top of another
on top of another on top of another on
top of another and that's why saturated
fats typically are solid at room
temperature okay as I just mentioned
Sapir saturated fats tend to be solid at
room temperature you know here's two
examples of saturated fats butter on the
left and you may not be familiar with
lard because it's kind of been phased
out as a cooking oil but lard is very
similar in texture and consistency as
butter you know in in the olden days
people would cook with lard they'd scoop
up some lard plop it in a frying pan you
know turn the heat on let it melt and
then you would have a cooking oil you
know maybe for making fried chicken or
something but saturated fats like butter
saturated fats like lard are typically
solid at room temperature for the
reasons I just mentioned you saw a
moment ago the picture of the saturated
chain of carbon-carbon single bonds
because those are typically form a
straight line across you're going to
have saturated fats stacked on top of
other saturated fats and the nice
compact stacking of molecules there
makes them solid at room temperature
these also saturated fats also typically
come from animals so the picture on the
left is our cow and butter is made from
cows milk the picture on the right is of
course pig and this is where lard comes
from lard 'simply pig fat so now well
now let's look at a fatty acid chain
that we say is unsaturated and I hope
you see a few differences in the picture
well first of all we still see a long
chain of carbon bonded to carbon the
difference though is that we can see in
this picture I only drew one double bond
but some unsaturated fatty acids will
have more than one double bond in
between a couple carbons but we can see
that there's a double bond that exists
this is gonna cause the chain to be
crooked it's not straight across any
more and that crookedness I'll mention
the importance of that in just a moment
but that crookedness is supposed to be
there in the picture it's not a bad
picture or a typo or anything and the
reason we say that this molecule is
unsaturated because of that double bond
there's less space for hydrogen atoms to
attach remember carbon needs eight
electrons to be full and stable if you
look at both of those carbons attached
to the double bond
they each have eight electrons there's
four dashes attached to the carbon on
the Left four dashes attached to the
carbon on the right that's a total of
eight electrons there's no reason to
have a another hydrogen bonded to either
of those carbons that would give it too
many electrons it already has enough so
this is what we mean by its unsaturated
because of that double bond there's less
space for hydrogen atoms you might know
that the unsaturated fats are the ones
that are typically better for you
they're not as unhealthy I should say so
if you try to limit your saturated fats
and and maybe substitute some
unsaturated fats for those who are
trying to be a little health-conscious
so unsaturated fats are typically
liquids at room temperature and the
reason is because of that crookedness
that you saw
the picture a moment ago because of that
double bond it makes the chain of
carbon-carbon bonds a little crooked
that's spreads out the molecule so that
way one fat excuse me one unsaturated
fatty acid doesn't really stack on top
of another one very well and that makes
the molecule spread out makes the more
liquid at room temperature so examples
of unsaturated fats are typically plant
oils you know for instance you may have
heard of coconut oil you I'm sure you
know coconut is a fruit grows on trees
another example of a of an unsaturated
plant oil might be olive oil you know we
have red olives on the Left green olives
on the right but again olive oil comes
from olives which grow in trees so these
are plant oils unsaturated fats again
typically are the ones that are
healthier for you so if we just kind of
put a picture of a saturated on top and
an unsaturated fatty acid on the bottom
if we just count up the hydrogen's
really quick and see you can see the
hydrogen's being counted in eighteen and
the saturated fat on top but because of
that double bond there's less room for
hydrogen to attach to the unsaturated
fatty acid on the bottom only 16 so that
double bond as I said earlier is going
to reduce the need for more hydrogen
atoms to stabilize the overall molecule
this is what we call an unsaturated
fatty acid on the bottom and on the top
it's what we call saturated because it's
full of hydrogen so one of the
applications of discussing lipids I want
to mention is that normally blood flows
freely in this case you see some red
blood cells flowing through an artery so
your hearts pump and red blood cells
around however however a person could
have high cholesterol levels in their
blood and over time you might get this
buildup of cholesterol this buildup of
plaque and it can Harden and form and
form kind of like a dam in a river and I
hope you see what's happening now as the
red blood cells continue to flow
the artery they're kind of getting
trapped and clogged by that wall of
cholesterol there and so a normal
healthy open artery might be reduced 50%
like you see in the picture this is
going to reduce circulation cause blood
clots and it could even cause high blood
pressure lead to stroke lead to heart
attack so you really want to watch your
cholesterol levels especially as you get
older and so the the medical condition
that I just referred to in that
animation right here is called ethereal
sclerosis and so you can see on the top
a normal artery nice and open in the
bottom of the picture we have an artery
that's been closed maybe 50 55 % with a
buildup of that yellow plaque in the
picture so this comes from a lifetime of
bad habits you know this doesn't happen
because you've eaten you eat McDonald's
and you supersize your french fries on a
Thursday night this happens over over a
lifetime so you really want to start if
you have a history of this in your
family or if if you have some signs of
there are the early signs of this you
may want to start you know talking to
your doctor about some some different
lifestyle choices you may want to
consider and if you are having your
blood cholesterol levels checked you
know here's a little table that might
tell you whether or not your cholesterol
levels are high if you're on the
borderline of being high
hopefully you're in the less than 200
range that's our desirable level of
cholesterol so there you go if you're in
my biology class pause the video and
answer these questions I'd love to check
them for accuracy either before school
or after school one day good and pause
the video good luck